as we spent some time yesterday talking
about his comments from more than a
month ago
on kyle brandt's podcast about covid19
and either we said it during the show or
i wrote it at profootballtalk.com or
both
but i saw what would happen
yesterday we envisioned it we knew that
there was going to be a clarification
after
kirk cousins made comments that you know
look
on the surface we're troubling you
understand what he's saying but even
then there was this sense that he's
using language is going to embolden the
anti-mass crowd it just was unfortunate
it cried out for clarification yesterday
kirk with 2k's cousins provided that
clarification
out of the gates out of the box as an
introductory statement
during a video conference with reporters
here's kirk cousins from yesterday
i probably wasn't as clear as i would
have liked to have been
um but what i wanted to say then what i
what i would echo again now
is that while the virus does not give me
a great amount of personal
fear um you know there's still great
reason for me to engage in
wearing a mask and social distancing and
you know washing my hands as frequently
as i can and and following protocols
that have been set in place
uh obviously to be respectful and
considerate of other people
uh which is very important but then also
um
you know to be available for all 16
games this fall
because as the protocol is set up if if
a player were to test positive they
would be
potentially out of the game or games and
so
uh you know there's there's plenty of
reasons to uh
to wear a mask social distance and be
very vigilant to uh
to help stop the spread of of the virus
so that was the heart
behind what i was trying to say in july
admittedly i didn't say it as clear as i
would have liked to
so i just want to you know share that
same message again and hopefully
articulate it a little bit better
but uh that that has always been my
heart and uh and is again now
he did articulate it better right he
couldn't have articulated it much worse
than he did on that podcast but
when i hear him say be respectful and
considerate it's almost like he's
talking about
you know don't put microwave or don't
put popcorn excuse me in the microwave
don't put fish in the microwave in the
office that's respectful and consider
this is a bigger issue than being
respectful and considerate
this is about not exposing people who
are at physical
risk of death to a virus
that can and in many cases will kill
them so it's it's
it's something stronger than being
respectful and considerate but but what
he said yesterday
was far better than what he said back in
july and chris i'm surprised that there
wasn't an effort to get ahead of this he
knew this was coming out
yeah did he just not connect did he not
think did he not
assume it was going to be a big deal i i
think in hindsight it would have been
better to find a way to get ahead of it
before that thing came out well he
probably didn't really realize
you know sometimes you get done with an
interview and you think i i articulated
that point pretty well i think it's good
and then you move on with life and oh
man okay now it's four weeks later and
it's thrown out in my face and oh
man i didn't articulate that point as
well as i would have liked i i mean i
think it's as simple as that
you know one just being around him
knowing people that know him you know
this is not a
jerk of a person this is not a bad guy a
mean guy there's no malice within him
he's got a lot of good with him
and yeah he doesn't fear it but yes i
think he's
completely aware of the consequences
that could happen and all of that
and uh yeah hopefully he cleared that up
a little bit and
i hear you with the language could have
been maybe a little stronger but still
i'm okay with it in all fairness and i
agree with you yeah good person
right good teammate good quarterback
there's an element of goofy there's an
element of
awkward and that may have been what came
through in the original comments that
filter
right that self-awareness right that
that maybe he doesn't have
the level that he should i remember in
the early years of the office one of the
producers explained
that the beauty of michael scott is that
michael scott is everywhere
and either you know a michael scott
in your own life or you don't which
means you're the michael scott
right and i would i would suggest that
kirk cousins does not know a michael
scott because i think he is the michael
scott
of the minnesota vikings and that's fine
michael scott ultimately at the end of
the day is a heartwarming lovable
character but from time to time
says things that in hindsight he
probably wishes he wouldn't have said
and i think that's what transpired
for kirk cousins got a little too
comfortable got a little too loose
didn't run the words through the filter
and it's surprising
because when he was asked the question
about where he lands on a scale of one
to ten
with one being masks or stupid and
you're all a bunch of lemmings
he said i'm not going to use the word
stupid because
i don't want to get accused of saying
the wrong thing so the filter was
on it just was in the right place and
wasn't in the right place yeah
and he just i think went a little you
know hard to prove his point where to
prove his point of
i'm not in fear of this you know he
might have gone too strong with like you
know the rocky four
if i die i'd die you know or if he dies
he dies right doesn't he say that about
apollo creed when he
knocks him out the russian but yeah i
just think there was some things there
where
yeah it got a little cocky or whatever
and and yes
just didn't guard his words quite
correctly or have the filter or whatever
it may be but
i know he's going to do the right things
for society and we'll continue to do
those i know that i i don't doubt that
one bit
uh and yeah you just hope guys can send
the proper verbal messages out there too
so we can all still just do the right
thing to squash this thing and move on
with life
and let me just say this before we break
far more than if i die
i die that use kind of flippantly of the
phrase survival of the fittest i think
rubbed a lot of people's wrong way right
because there's an arrogance to that
and and also just kind of an acceptance
hey hey
sorry if you're sick right if you can't
keep up
it's the it's the uh wildebeest that
can't keep up with the pack
that gets eaten by the lions sorry see
you later
we're out of here so that that i and we
we noticed that in real time yeah
survival of the fittest yeah and and as
the day unfolded i heard more and more
from people saying there's really
you know that that's more problematic
than saying if i die i die hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports